[Music]
[Music]
welcome back today we're going to begin
our study of hieroglyphs by learning the
Egyptian alphabet and how to write our
names in hieroglyphs but first I have to
give you the answer to the homework
question what does this ancient Egyptian
sentence say I've been teaching this
course for 40 years and I'm always
surprised at how consistent the guesses
are almost everyone thinks it's about
birds and going somewhere which is
perfectly reasonable since we see Birds
feet and so on but reasonable is not
necessarily correct the sentence has
nothing to do with feet walking or birds
everyone's making the same mistake that
the scholars trying to decipher
hieroglyphs were making assuming that
the hieroglyphs are a hundred percent
idea graphic that is picture writing
that when you have a bird the text is
talking about birds it's not this is
what I call the big mistake in fact this
sentence translates to the sun is
shining in the sky let me explain why
hieroglyphs for the most part are
phonetic and represents sounds the first
bird is a quail chick and it represents
the sound w the foot has a sound but
Abby and the wavy line is an N this
circle at the end though is IDIA graphic
it represents the Sun and helps make
clear the meaning of webbing it's the
word for shine so two things to note
about our first Egyptian word first it's
mostly phonetic with no vowels and often
we don't know which vowels were used
second and ideograph excite at the end
provides a clue to the words meaning the
second word in our sentence
is made up of three hieroglyphs a mouth
sign or an arm ah and our Sun Circle
again which has no sound but helps make
the meaning clear so the sound is rare
and it means Sun next comes an owl
that's pronounced mmm and it means in
our last word has a rectangle which is a
puff and a semicircle which is a tough
so it's pronounced pet the hieroglyph
under it represents the sky the
Egyptians viewed the sky as a canopy
held up by four pillars and the word
means sky note how the word for sky is
formed two small hieroglyphs together
above a longer one the ancient Egyptians
were very concerned with aesthetics they
wanted their words and sentences to look
good if you strung out the three
hieroglyphs on one line it wouldn't look
nearly as good
so our sentence means the sun is shining
in the sky nothing about birds feet or
arms we should also notice that the verb
shine comes at the start of the sentence
verbs come first in ancient Egyptian I
should point out that sometimes in
Egyptian just as in English there is
some ambiguity the word webbing to shine
also means to rise so your sentence
could also be translated as the Sun is
rising in the sky in our sentence
hieroglyphs are actually used two ways
phonetically to represent sounds but
also as pictures to help us determine
the meanings of phonetic words like the
Sun and sky hieroglyphs these signs are
called determinative because they help
us determine the meaning of a word
there's one more way that high rulers
can be
and that's as ideograms ideograms our
hieroglyphs used pictorially but not at
the end of the word rather ideograms
stand alone to help you recognize that
they're standing alone they are often
flagged in the ancient Egyptian language
with a stroke so we could do some speed
writing and for son we could write this
the son with a stroke
so to summarize hieroglyphs can be used
in three ways
first phonetically representing a sound
second as a determinative coming at the
end of a word to clarify its meaning and
third as an ideogram where the picture
represents a concept all by itself we
will get lots of practice with all three
uses of hieroglyphs and they'll become
familiar with repetition so don't worry
now it's time to learn the ancient
Egyptian alphabet I'll show you how to
write each hieroglyph step by step for
just a heads up
there's no letters L o V or X in middle
Egyptian I'll show you how to draw an L
lion that was used much later during the
Ptolemaic period but don't be surprised
when we skip right over some other
letters now
get some paper and a pencil or pen let
me give you one tip to improve your
hieroglyphic penmanship use a fine point
felt-tip pen hieroglyphs were intended
to be drawn with a brush a felt-tip pen
will approximate the brush let's start
with a now i know i said that the
egyptians didn't write vowels and i'm
showing you an a it's not exactly the
sound of our a philologist call it semi
vocalic like the arabic i een it may
have sounded a bit like the O and Otto
even now for this sound we're gonna draw
a vulture watch the steps and then
follow along when I draw it a second
time we start with the beak something
like that next we go with the front of
the body
then give him front legs we come down
for the back give him the back wings
come up for his leg give him something
to stand on and you've got a vulture now
let's do it again I'll do it slowly
you'll see the sequence start with your
beak do the front
give him his front legs come down with
the back back wings come over up with
the leg and always the bird stand on
something that's our letter A ah this is
one of the most difficult of the
alphabetic hieroglyphs don't worry if
you're having trouble you'll get it
everyone does
remember our exercise book also shows
you how to draw it step by step
be is afoot start with a line down then
you're just gonna need a triangle coming
over here come back and then you've got
the back of the foot be line down
triangle come back and bring it down and
you've got a foot it's very stylized
there's no real sea but we have a CH
sound like in the Scottish Loch
it's a placenta you just draw a circle
and put three lines across and you've
got it
sometimes there's four lines across it
doesn't matter which and that's our CH
sound d is a hand
it's stylized not realistic now start
with an oval then draw the wrist like
that and now comes the thumb it almost
looks like a mitten so you do the oval
the wrist and the thumb and that's d e
is an arm it's one of those semi vocalic
sounds not quite a vowel now start with
the fingers of the hand like that
then go with the arm and then the
shoulder the shoulder isn't a square
it's got a little bit of a down like
that and that's the e so remember you
just do the thumb you do the hand
underneath it you bring the arm all the
way out and then you go up and you've
got the shoulder and that's the e sound
F is a snake the horned Viper start with
the head and body like that and then
just give him the two horns and that's
it he's very stylized so you just give
him the body and then two horns and
you've got it the F G is a jurist and
it's not a teepee it's a hard G sound as
in guarantee often desert civilizations
created round-bottom pots they could set
up right in the sand
indoors you needed a stand for the pot
usually made of clay the bottom of the
pot would rest in it the triangle cutout
is to allow a breeze to go through and
COO your water in the jar now let me
show you how to draw the jar stand start
with two vertical lines like that
now the curved bottom it's a little bit
of perspective put in the top and then
your little triangle so you get the
breeze to cool your water and that's the
jurist and once again two vertical lines
the nice curved bottom through the top
straight across and your triangle so you
have cool water and that's your letter G
now for H there are actually two
different ages in the Egyptian alphabet
the reed hut H is a simple structure
made of reeds so the farmer can get out
out of the blistering Sun for a while
it's all straight lines let me show you
you go up across down across and up
again like that so
straight lines and that's one of the H's
the other H is a twisted flex and it's
surprisingly difficult to draw it
represents two strands of flax twisted
together now it looks like three loops
one on top of the other but don't draw
it that way it just doesn't come out
right let's do it the way the ancient
scribes did it start with a curve at the
top bring another one down and then
finish the bottom that's your twisted
flax H start with a curve at the top
bring another one down and finish your
bottom and that's it the difference
between the two H's is that the reed hut
is more emphatic as in hot where you
expel your breath forcefully the flax h
is not so emphatic it's more like the h
in hello
now on to i another semi vowel
I is a read leaf
the kind that flowers by the seashore it
probably was vocalized like the eye in
it now start with a straight line then
give it a rounded top like that then
come down parallel and then finish it
off with another curved line and that's
your read leaf stir it one more time
down curve a top straight down and then
give it another curve and that's it for
J we have a snake we think it's a Cobra
it's really a DJ sound as in judge first
start with a head come down across and
down and that's it
the king is getting the angles it's
really right angles almost so start with
a head come down across and down and
that's your J or DJ K is easy it's a
basket with a handle draw a slice of a
circle and then just through the handle
at an angle coming down like that and
that's your K let's try it again
just drew your slice of a circle and the
handle coming down looks like a coffee
cup but it's a basket
as I said before there is no L in the
ancient Egyptian alphabet this would be
added later we're studying middle
Egyptian the language spoken around 2000
BC later the Greeks would use a lion for
their ELLs in their names like Ptolemy
and Cleopatra if your name is Lily
you'll want to know how to draw it so
let me show you one now for the lion
start with the rectangle for the head
then do the mane
next you can do the body give them a
tail and then you can do hindquarters
front legs and if you have time you can
give the nose it's kind of cartoony but
you can do it quickly that way let me
show you one more time
start with the rectangle for the face
then his mane next the body the tail
back legs front legs and you can even
give them those and that's your lion L
so there you go Lilly M is another bird
an owl the key thing is to start with
the head which looks like this it's an
unusual bird because it's looking
frontally at you usually the bird you
can't see frontally now we do everything
exactly the same as the a the vulture we
start with the front we give them as
front legs we come down with the back
feathers the back we come up for the leg
and give them something to stand on and
if you have a little time give them this
distinctive beak and you've got an owl
let's try it again
start with the rectangle up here the
unfinished rectangle then go for the
front of the body the front leg now come
down just like the vulture for the back
come across
up for the tail feathers and give him
something to stand on and we'll give him
his beak that's your M sometimes instead
of the owl Egyptian scribes used another
hieroglyph it's a base upon which a
statue stood we'll see it later in the
course and I'll remind you about it but
let me show you how to draw it it's very
simple
you just come across and front and back
and that's the statue base so it's just
a cross down at an angle and back either
the owl or the statue base same thing
and now for n it's simple up and down
Peaks the word for water was none so
it's not surprising that the ideogram
for water also represents the sound hmm
now let's do it here up and down up and
down there's no specific number of Peaks
you can do four or five but the
important thing is the ends have to go
down so let's do it one more time and
that's your end I believe that the water
sign may have been the first hieroglyph
there are early water jars with wavy
line designs it's the first label ever
from this we can go on to create the
Norma palette remember it's all labels
for Narmer the servant the Vizier and
now back to our alphabet like L there's
no o in the ancient Egyptian alphabet so
we'll skip over o and go straight to P P
is a rectangle not a square and
represents a woven read mat it's simple
just do a rectangle and you've got it
let's do it one more time
that's Pig you may be wondering how we
know that this rectangle is a reed Matt
well on tomb walls when the hieroglyph
is drawn in detail we often see the
weaving queue is just a hill it has a
slightly different sound from the basket
kay we just learned think about the
difference in the initial sounds of
Queen and Kidd the queue is almost a kW
sound let me show you how to do it draw
the bottom line of the hill then the top
and then it's curved down to the bottom
like that that's Q so again just do the
bottom come up and curve it down to the
bottom and that's your Q R is a mouth
first just do the top and then the
bottom and that's it
just the top and then the bottom and
you've got our the letter s looks like a
cane but it isn't it's a bolt of folded
cloth don't try to draw it in one single
line it just doesn't come out well that
way do it in three strokes
we know that the scribes did it that way
because we can see brushstrokes and even
where the ink and the brush began to run
out so start with a vertical line then
do a shorter parallel line and then
connect the two and that'll always come
out nicely again your vertical line your
parallel connect the two
and you've got it tea is real easy it's
just a semicircle it's a loaf of bread
start with the bottom and just do the
top and that's your letter T one more
that's your letter T the U is our third
and last bird in the alphabet
he's a quail chick now start with the
head and then when you do the body the
thing about the quail chick is it's
mostly straight lines so when you come
down do it like that you can come across
for here do it here and now you've got
the feet put in a wing
give him his beak and you got your quail
chicken let's try them again start with
the head then we can come down here now
if you want you can draw the parallel
line here first then connect now you
give him feet he's going to walk
put them on something complete the face
with the beak coming down and give him
his wing and that's your quail chick
there's no V in our alphabet so we go to
W but W is also the Quayle check that we
used for you now there's also no X Y is
the read written twice it has the sound
of a long e like in Mary so just with
our I we start with a straight line we
give them a curve at the top come down
and then give it the other curve and
we're going to do it twice straight line
curve come down and that's the Y sound
we'll do one more time straight line
curve at the top come down like that
straight line up at the top come down
curve and that's the Y sound Z is a
bolt-on ad or the kind of slides when
written it's simply this do it again
just you'll see it's a line like that
now when you actually see it you'll see
that it's much more complicated but for
writing it they just did it this way now
there are just two more hieroglyphs to
complete our alphabet there for sounds
for which English doesn't use a single
letter the sound is really one sound but
in English we have to use two letters to
represent it s and H the ancient
Egyptians use the pool of water for the
SH sound just draw a rectangle and
that's your pool of water so it's just a
long thin pool and once in a while
they'd put two lines in it to indicate
water so that's the SH sound
last is the sound sure this is
represented by a tethering ring it was
used to keep animals from running away
put each loop over a hoof and your
donkey isn't going anywhere let me show
you how to do it start by drawing the
two loops this is what's gonna fit over
the donkey tubes and then the string and
that's your tethering ring so two loops
and then that's it that's now let's
write our names in the Egyptian alphabet
note that we're not translating our
names we're not working at the level of
meanings we're just transcribing our
names from one alphabet to another
this is transliteration let's say your
name is Andrea Schwartz well for the a
sound we start with the vulture next we
have an n the water sign then we have
the hand D we start with the oval do the
wrist the thumb we're getting there
next we have an R right now I put one
sign on top of the other if you have too
short signs they can go one on top of
the other because remember the Egyptians
liked it to look good so now we have the
mouth hieroglyph which is easy and then
we need the arm for the app we're gonna
stack them again there's our
Andrey yeah and then we have an a at the
end maybe so that's the Andrea now for
Schwartz let's go by the sound right now
Schwartz is a sound really so I think we
can use something like the SH good now
we can have a quail chick maybe a right
now next we're gonna have an r T Z so
we're gonna have three short signs let's
stack them up sometimes the Egyptians
would do that so we got the war now we
have the T we have an arm the T and the
Z together that would be your Schwarz
there you can see how I stack the three
hieroglyphs just because they would like
it because look better that way that's
how we write Andrea Schwartz in
hieroglyphs well it's been a big lesson
we've learned the three ways that a
hieroglyph can be used the hieroglyphic
alphabet had a right hieroglyphs and how
to position them that's quite a lot we
just have to practice a bit to let it
all sink in let me give you a homework
assignment online paper practice writing
one line of each hieroglyphs do a line
of vultures then the foot and so forth
don't rush it enjoy it our exercise book
will show you how to draw the alphabetic
hieroglyphs just follow the step-by-step
instructions for each one I think you'll
really enjoy the process I find drawing
hieroglyphs to be a therapeutic escape
from a frantic day or when I'm stuck
listening to a not so interesting
lecture I take out my felt to pen and I
draw hieroglyphs I have a hunch that I'm
not the only one of my colleagues who
does that I'll see you next time